let me ask you about some of the things
you see in this country from your from
your perspective of everywhere you've
been in the world what do you think
about the black lives matter movement
here in america that
does
struggle
with the role of
um
skin color or today
and throughout the history of this
country maybe even throughout the
history of the world
well black lives matter has been a very
hard one for me
because do black lives matter those
three words together in that order what
they mean
they mean everything because black lives
do matter as any of our lives do matter
but i know in this case why they say
black lives matter because some of the
contexts we have had
now
while i agree with the principles that
black lives matter i have a big problem
with the organization
and what it stands for
when i have an organization that
pretends to want to stand for black
lives to matter
yet you are
self-proclaimed
marxist socialist
i pause
why
i pause and then i'm like have we
learned nothing
have we learned nothing and the reason
why i say that
lex is because
60 some years ago
it started before even 60 some years ago
black people in this case um i'm talking
about the african people
i'm talking about
the black africans who would go on
to really um cement
this um concept of
african emancipation and african
liberation
and here i'm taking us back to 1945
it's they were they had four of them
before that but in 1945
in manchester uk
happened something that would become
major for
for africa
and its future especially sub-saharan
africa
manchester uk
people like blaisdyan of my country
neareray tanzania
kwame nkrumah ghana
and others and others from different
parts of the continent
got together
with marcus garvey
and w.e.b dubois
and i said dubois because that's how he
stated in french he has a french name
uh french name at least and americans
will say so for america's listening i
know you said dubois
but
no because just in case i like who
you're talking about that's what i'm
talking about
um
so all of those people got together in
the uk yes
and with w.e.b dubois and marcus garvey
big top african-american intellectuals
of their times
um www had so many things happened to
him you know starting from the north
being more more or less a liberal type
guy you know
um came to the south just to see um at
this time you know people black people
being lynched and some of the body parts
been shown in store windows i mean just
for a second
we put ourselves in his shoes
i put myself in his shoes
and that's when he started to become
radicalized right because at first it
was like oh reforms we said that and i
was like god darn it enemies people we
don't talk to them we force you know
and eventually little by little things
going through
um yeah you you have these people
they're very much on the
marxist socialist train
so you think the la the sort of
it's the political movements that are
just using
yeah because what happened back in those
days
it is true
that to their credit
communist socialists were fighting for
equal rights
they were fighting for the rights of
black people to have equal rights
so
of course
i could see why one could say especially
in those times
you're been lynched
bodies burnt
body parts
showcased at
windows stores
meanwhile in africa
under colonization
in your own country in your own land
and
you have this group but saying
we
your fight
is part of what we fight
of course you're gonna say side with you
especially if this is all happening at a
time
where you know so 1945
these guys
who would be
the liberators of various african
nations for meeting
with garvey
with w.e.b dubois
and um that's where pretty this meeting
is very important it's the fifth
pan-african congress meeting it's very
important it could be the last one but
it's the most important one because
that's when they formed their plans and
um and really the rallied around this
concept of african administration
emancipation and um african liberation
we're going to liberate our countries
then later so that's how all of this
movement started to happen and um from
there gandhi was already making some
progress with india you know getting
them out of
british rule and all of that so all of
this was happening and really like this
whole thing was bubbling bubbling
bubbling you know like there's like a
new force going on
and then we arrive in the late 50s
and um you know kuma with um
the you know them with the british as
well they might manage to become to
become
um the their colonization is is over
they're the first one to go in 57 then
from there it's what we call the
independences that's what when afr most
of sub-saharan african nations are
getting very independent it's different
dates mine april 4th 1960 so all over so
this is happening and now think about it
you're talking 57 you're talking 60.
we're like at the we're like at this
time now with uh the middle of a cold
war because we have to put things in
context if we want to understand what's
going on because people today ask me why
do you think um because even now when
they understand oh you're right um it
makes sense if you have no economic
freedom you're going to be poor but why
why why did they go for this why did
they go for this and they don't
understand so that's what happened so
beginning of day of times pre-colonial
africans were free marketeers free
enterprise it's pretty well recorded by
someone like george aide that's where i
got the cheat i think from
and getting an economist and then
slavery happened colonism happened and
then the independences um late 50s early
60s for most countries for most african
most sub-saharan african countries so
there what you have is um
but then what happened there so i told
you in 45 fifth and african congress in
the uk with um the liberators of africa
um under the um under the leadership
because he was the the wise you know
eldest man um
dubois was he was in his 70s back in the
day so he's older than them you know and
he's coming with all of his ideas and
everything so we're like
so there we are now in their late 50s
early 60s we're starting to make
progress with the independences you know
india has gone there before so all of
that is starting to happen
and at that time
remember they they already were being
introduced to the concept of socialism
marxism all of that way before
by some of these you know um black
african-american intellectuals of their
time who are very socialist marxists by
that time
so now they're becoming independent
because i do i do independent like this
because i i reckon that there's still
neocolonism going on
so
now this is happening
we're becoming free but then you look
around what do you see that now
most of his liberators of their nations
become the president of the nations but
remember what i told you most of them
have
drunken the social socialist marxist
socialism kool-aid
so as these african nations become
independent with their first independent
governments and um you know presidents
most of them most of them
are socialists
various forms of statist type of
government
and this is because at that point we had
made a fatal mistake
of going of um saying
um
we are marxist socialists because you
guys fight for equal rights uh so in
this case there should be no colonism or
anything like that
and so not only you have that going on
and the people so right now you had this
battle of ideology going on because on
one end represented by
freedom and the economic what do you
call it the economic system they were
using is capitalism and these are
represented by the western nations
facing off with eastern bloc
practicing various forms of statism
socialism communism various forms of
statism
and these two are fighting for influence
so and we also have it's also not so two
things there one is we're at a time
where
remember the free market concept was
almost dead almost dead
so almost every intellectual at that
time
was social marxist
or marxist socialist i put your name
that's what you wear so you're in a
world where it was a normal thing it was
just mainstream
acceptance so not only you have that
force but at the same time
if these two forces are fighting one
another it turns out that the one
representing capitalism and freedom
well sorry but isn't it you who enslaved
us and colonized us
and you're fighting with
with the people who represent you know
um supposedly people who are saying that
uh who had been fighting for equal
rights for us with us for the longest
time these are our friends
and that's when we made a fatal mistake
because while yes there were maybe good
things
um to agree on with uh marxist
socialists of the times i especially you
know
equal rights for for all people and all
of that that's the only thing we should
have among the only things we should
have agreed upon there are violent
revolution tendencies no way uh when it
comes to um the economic nonsense no way
we should not have thrown the baby out
with the bathwater but that's what we
did and that's when we made a fatal
mistake so then we became
free all of these nations and most of
them started with socialist or communist
leaders my country
socialists uh leopold
he was a socialist
and they stayed in power for 40 years
the first 40 years of our
freedom years
and all over the continent more or less
that's what you had and on top of that
something else that the french don't
know the people don't know is france
with its colonies said you cannot
not do um you have to um you have to
keep
the french
french civil law so we're talking about
the napoleonic
civil code
are you kidding me
so that's what happened so the reason
why i go back to blm
is while
i have
all the respect in the world
and all the compassion in the world
for people like kruma for people like me
railway for people all of us people of
those times the liberators of africa
while i have so much love compassion for
them
i am also able to say
because i got the benefit of 60 some
years time
and you know where you get to
to do a debrief
and see what worked what didn't work
what happened
we have had the 60 years to look back
and to reflect
so yes
i can understand why they did what they
did
i cannot even i can understand
why they sided with these people who on
the surface or at least some part of a
fight with the same fight as them when
it came to equal rights
i can excuse them
but i will not
excuse
the blm founders
because that mistake
was tolerable
60 some years ago today
no
the blacks of today
cannot
be serious about black lives mattering
and saying in the same sentence
and we're going to be socialist marks
mark's a socialist if this doesn't work
so the blm movement is too
deeply integrated with with the ideas
ideologically marxism yeah
they're anti-free market
anti-capitalist
and we do know
that you have
to have the free markets in order to
build prosperity
and
prosperity means economic power
if you have economic power
no one messes with you or if they're
gonna do it they're gonna have to think
twice and when they do they're gonna
have to pay consequences
so if you if you want for blacks to be
respected anywhere in the world
you're gonna have to be serious about
black prosperity
omas not just a few people oprah over
here and somebody have a vet
no
we as a group
have to be
a critical mass of prosperity across the
board
and because we're talking critical mass
of prosperity across the board it means
black people everywhere in the world
but guess what we in africa happen to
represent 90 of our representatives of a
black race so you're going to be serious
about black black lives mattering
without being serious for africa the one
billion people in africa that are black
and for them to have access to the free
markets and yes fossil fuels so that
they can
rocket you know up
prosperity-wise and the resources of the
young people the young minds so that all
of these young people young minds can
finally manifest their greatness that i
know they have and that they're showing
you us every day despite despite the
obstacles
that's what we need
senegal becomes rich and senegal can
become and will be richer than france
the colonized singapore did it we can do
it
maliwich
nigeria rich functioning as well
mali uh malawi rich tanzania rich
ugandan rich zimbabwe rich
niger rich
everywhere rich prosperous
as prosperous if not more prosperous
than than than switzerland or singapore
or the u.s i don't know of all of
alician chinese or luxembourg places
that have no um you know
resource resource natural resources
we become rich
and you watch the world having a very
different uh relationship with us that's
the only time
we will command any type of respect
that's when
people even the
our common psyche will change even about
black people all of the stereotypes that
they have of us
is gonna melt away
and you may still not like us
but you will still respect us because we
are a force to be to be dealt with and
only economic power does that it would
be nice of course
for us to respect people because they're
people it would be nice but let us not
kid ourselves this is this is earth and
someone said you know nice people will
make it to heaven but not to harvard
necessarily it's true it's interesting
that uh pity
does not
ever turn into respect
it would be nice if it did it would be
nice but it doesn't
prosperity prosperity is the only thing
and the way we do that there is no
just like all of us humans have to
inject have to inhale
oxygen
and excel
carbon dioxide that's a human way of
breathing
you bring me on but you want to be
foolish and be like oh well
sorry that's how white people breathe so
as black people we're gonna have to do
something different well good luck with
that
right so this is here why i'm saying i
have no patience for black lives matter
we're making a mistake that was made
60 some plus years ago
even more than that maybe even 100 you
know when we were siding with a marxist
socialist because they're the ones
who've been fighting for equal rights
you